What about unsupervised learning?
>> Right, so unsupervised learning
we don't get those examples.
We have just essentially
something like input, and
we have to derive some structure
from them just by looking at
the relationship between
the inputs themselves.
>> Right so give me an example of that.
>> So.
When you're studying different kinds
of animals, say, even as a kid.
>> Mm-hm.
>> You might start to say, oh,
there's these animals that
all look kind of the same.
They're all four-legged.
I'm going to call all of them dogs.
Even if they happen to be horses,
or cows, or whatever.
But I have developed,
without anyone telling me,
this sort of notion that all
these belong in the same class.
And it's different
from things like trees.
Which don't have four legs.
>> Well some do, but I mean, they have,
they both bark, is all I'm saying.
>> Did I really set you up for that?
>> Not on purpose.
>> I, I'm sorry, I want to apologize
to each and every one of you for that.
But that was pretty good.
Michael is very good at word play.
Which I guess is often
unsupervised as well.
No, I get a lot of [LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH] You certainly
get a lot of feedback.
>> Yeah, that's right.
So I say, please stop doing that.
>> So if supervised learning is
about function approximation,
then unsupervised learning
is about description.
It's about taking a set of data and
figuring out how you might divide
it up in one way or the other.
>> Or maybe even summarization
it's not just the description but
it's a shorter description.
>> Yeah, it's usually concise.
Compression.
>> Compact description.
So I might take a bunch of pixels
like I have here it might say, male.
>> [LAUGH] Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm pixels now?
>> As far as we can tell.
>> That's fine.
>> I however, am not pixels.
I know I'm not pixels.
I'm pretty sure the rest
of you are pixels.
>> That's right.
>> So I have a bunch of pixels, and
I might say male.
And or I might say female.
Or I might say dog.
Or I might say tree.
But, the point is I don't have a bunch
of labels that say dog, tree, male,
or female.
I just decide that pixels like
this belong with pixels like this.
As opposed to pixels like something
else that I'm pointing to behind me.
>> Yeah we're living in a world right
now that is devoid of any other objects.
Oh, chairs!
>> Chairs!
Right.
So these pixels are very different
than those pixels because of
where they are relative
to the other pixels.
Say, right?
So, if you were looking-
>> I'm not sure that's helping me
understand unsupervised learning.
>> Go out and, go outside and
look at a crowd of people and try to
decide how you might divide them up.
Maybe you'll divide
them up by ethnicity.
Maybe you'll divide them up by
whether they have purposefully shaven
their hair in order to mock the bald or
whether they have curly hair.
Maybe you'll divide them
up by whether they have
goatees,
>> Facial hair.
>> Or whether they have grey hair,
there's lots of things that
you might do in order,.
>> Did you just point at me and
say grey hair?
>> I was pointing and
your head happened to be there.
>> Oh come on.
>> Pixels,
>> Where's the grey hair?
>> It's a two dimensional, right there,
it's right where your spit curl is.
All right.
>> Okay.
So, imagine you're dividing the world
up that way.
You could divide it up male, female.
You could divide it up short, tall,
wears hats, doesn't wear hats,
all kinds of ways you can divide it up.
And no one's telling you the right way
to divide it up, at least not directly.
That's unsupervised learning.
That's description, because now-
>> Mm.
>> Rather than having to send pixels of
everyone, or having to do a complete
description of this crowd,
you can say there were 57 males and
23 females say.
Or there are mostly people with beards.
>> So on.
>> Or whatever.
>> I like summarization for that.
That seems good.
>> Yeah.
>> It's a nice concise description.
That's unsupervised learning.
>> Good.
Very good.
>> And practice.
>> And that's different from
supervised learning?
>> It's different in supervised learning
and it's different in a couple of ways.
One way that it's different
is all of those ways that we
could have just divided up the world.
In some sense are all equal either.
So I could divide up by sex or
I could divide up by height or I could
divide up by clothing or whatever.
And they're all equally good absent
some other signal later telling you
how you should be dividing up the world.
But supervised learning directly
tells you there's a signal.
This is what it ought to be,
and that's how you train.
And those are very different.
>> Now, but I could see ways that
unsupervised learning could be helpful
in the supervised setting, right?
So if I do get a nice description, and
it's the right kind of description,
it might help me map to, it may help me
do the function approximation better.
>> Right, so instead of taking
pixels that input, as input, and,
and labels like, male or female.
I could just simply take a summarization
of you like how much hair do
you have your relative height,
the weight, and
various things like that
that might help me do it.
That's right.
And by the way,
in practice this turns out to be
things like density estimation.
We do end up turning it into
statistics at the end of the day.
Often.
>> But
it's statistics from the beginning.
But when you say density estimation.
>> Yes.
>> Are you saying I'm stupid?
No.
>> All right so
what is density estimation?
>> Well they'll have to
take the class to find out.
>> I see.
>> Okay